alors côté cinéma toujours avait lieu
hier l'avant-première du grand méchant
loup donc au sirano à Versailles en
présence des deux réalisateurs donc
c'était assez exceptionnel le film a
d'ailleurs été tourné à Versailles il
faut le noter alors c'est l'histoire de
trois frères qui le jour où leur mère à
un accident se mettent tout d'un coup à
se questionner sur le sens de leur vie
une vague de doute les emporte ce sont
des carantenaires Versaillais sans
histoire a priori mais cela suffit à
leur faire entrreouvrir la porte à
l'inédit à l'interdit à l'aventure
peut-être même au grand méchant ça fait
envie le grand méchant alors dans ce
film onouve on retrouve une play
d'acteurs notamment cadmerad Fred testo
Zabou Breitman Charlotte Le Bon et nous
nous avons rencontré en exclusivité
benoî poulevord et Léa Drucker qui vont
nous livrer leur impression quant au
tournage je suis marié une fille qui a
vécu ici 20 ans à parl on n pas loin de
versaill donc j'ai force camarade dans
la salle qui ne sont pas évidemment je
ne suis pas un versaillis mais mon
épouse a vécu ici toute son enfance et
donc quand je suis revenu ici tourner
parce que le film se fait entièrement à
versaill tout de même j'étais
extrêmement content que ma femme d'abord
retrouve le pays de sa jeunesse et que
j'apprécie
grandement sans devoir être comme un
beau fils de dire écoute je suis très
heureux ici bon tu me diras j'étais pas
mal logé j'ai d' non comment s'est passé
justement le tournage
ah mais ça il faut voir le film on s'est
marré comme des des
pétés ah le
château visite du
château le château c'était formidable
parce que les gens étaient extrêmement
accueillants en même temps c'était une
période il faisait quand même assez
froid et alors c'est très paradoxal mais
quand tu tournes dans le Palais des
Glaces il fait extrêmement chaud
là-dedans alors j'ai dit mais couper le
chauffage qu qu'and on est une nuit je
sais pas si vous avez vu le film mais il
et en fait non c'est juste le soleil en
quoi l'architecte quand même quand même
très très fort c'est le soleil de la
journée qui s'accumule ah les
impressions sur le tournage elles
étaient bonnes elles étaient
particulières moi j'étais en uniforme de
de policière municipal pendant tout le
film quasiment j'ai fait un petit stage
au lilas et la dernière fois je suis
venu ici d'ailleurs on était sur la
place de nuit avec benoirt les
impressions elles sont excellentes
c'était génial de travailler avec Fred
testo etfin d'avoir pour partenaire Fred
et Benoît euh CAD malheureusement pas
assez
car don s'est croisé dans des séquences
à l'hôpital mais j'aurais bien aimé
avoir plus de scènes avec lui j'étais
bien
entouréelia c'est c'est qui le grand
méchant loup et bien le grand méchant
loup c'est en fait le désir la tentation
alors homme ou femme tout dépend dans
quel rôle on situe mais globalement
c'est ça alors justement pour les
réalisateurs ce film donc c'est une
comédie on le rappelle donc on rit mais
soulève néanmoins certaines réflexion
donc sur les hommes sur les femmes le
désir la place du couple dans la société
on les écoute qui suis-je suis-je devenu
celui que je voulais être peut-on aimer
deux personnes en même temps est-il
temps de fermer 68 dans ma tête suis-je
armé pour ça ai-je la culture de la
Révolution est-ce qu'on peut parler de
la place du du couple bien sûhme femme
de l'homme et la femme qu'est-ce qu'être
un homme aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'être
un homme aujourd'hui en 2013 alors que
bien des choses ont changé que mademè
est loin derrière nos grand-pères en ont
bien profité et mtenant bah il faut
réinventer des choses vous pensez que la
place de l'homme est plus difficile à
prendre ah bien sûr bien sûr ah ouioui
il faut tout réinventer maintenant bah
parce
que parce que c'est flou aujourd'hui on
ne peut plus nous jeunes garçons de de
de de 40 ans on peut plus se reposer sur
les sur les sur les les les les rapports
hommes-femmes
ancestraux sur le modèle patriarcal
exactement donc il faut tout réinventer
et donc il faut essayer des choses se
poser des questions et tant qu'on se
pose des questions est vivant voilà et
si possible en rigolant c'est ce que par
c'est une comédie absolument c'est une
comédie on on rit de de tout ça on rit
il y a du comicque de situation il y a
la comédie de pied dans le tapis qui
fait beaucoup rire et puis il y a la
comédie de MS de la de de oui de c'est
un film qui a un fort pouvoir
d'identification en fait alors voilà le
grand chanloup sera donc dans nos salles
obscures à compter du 10 juillet